Okay, now it's my left ear. Hello Soren.
How are you? Good. How are you doing?
I'm good. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And so far we've been talking about the
value of our lives and then the value of
other people's lives.
Next up, the value of
[inaudible]
everything, all of it. Everything. Re
think I'm by everything. Of course.
We mean the value of nature.
That's Carl Zimmer, science writer,
regular blower of minds.
So we think of ecosystems as
just kind of sitting there.
Um, actually they're doing things.
They weren't doing them for us.
We would have to pay to do
them artificially. For example,
cotton farms in south Texas. So you
know, the farmers are doing their thing.
Like this Guy James Parker plant in their
cotton. They're collecting it. Yeah,
I farmed about, I don't know, usually
five to six, 700 acres of cotton.
So say 2000 bales. They're
doing what farmers do.
I spent a lot of time on a tractor and uh,
you have to check your water every
morning, every evening. Meanwhile,
they have all this extra
help in the air. Yes,
they have bats. How many bats are
out there? You really don't know.
Flying all around the bats
eat the equivalent of two
thirds of their own weight
in insects every night. Wow.
They eat all night long.
All kinds of bugs.
A whole bunch of pests that would
otherwise be eating the cotton. No.
A few years ago,
guy named John Westfall did a calculation
just to see how this arrangement was
working out. He came out to my
farm and did it. He did a study,
he had some college girls that worked for
him and those girls were out there all
hours of the night listening to what the
baths were saying and here the farmers
collectively, they make about four
or $5 million off of the these farms.
The question was how much of
this was because of the batch?
Cause you know baths are
natural pesticides, you know
the more they're eating.
Alyssa,
I got a spray and here's what the
scientists figured out out of four to $5
million, it was around $700,000
that you could describe to the bats.
It's just beautiful. Wow. I mean,
it does make me think that
if you're those farmers,
you should be compensating
the bets. Yeah. Well, yeah,
it does give you a glimpse at
the kind of scale of value,
economic value that nature has that
we generally just totally ignore.
But we talked to a guy who didn't
ignore it. My name is Robert Costanza.
In fact, he took this way of
thinking to the absolute limit. Yes.
So the question was what's the value
of all of these ecosystem services
globally? All the services on earth?
Yeah, it's bugs. Eating leaves, worms,
turning the soil needles,
chewing tree stump,
or always protecting cities
during storms, everything.
We tried to synthesize all of the studies
that had been done around the country
in the world, like that bat study, except
they didn't just look cotton farms,
they looked at tropical forests,
rivers and lakes, coral reefs,
coastal wetlands, and then wetlands,
the ocean woodlands, temporary forest,
you know, it goes on and on grasslands,
it's supposed to be some
excel spreadsheet. It's,
it's kind of the excel spreadsheet
from hell. It can get tricky.
So Constanza and his colleagues
took all these different studies.
Some of them together did
a whole bunch of half and
came up with a number,
which in today's dollars is 142 point
$7 trillion per year of services.
That's more than all of the ghosts
national products of the world.
That's how valuable the
services of nature are. Yeah.
Let me ask you, like I get the, I get
the way this would work with a bat,
like the bats eating the bugs,
but like how do you do
it with like with like a,
like a field or something? Like do you
just walk through and you're like, Oh,
that's 20 bucks of services. That's 50.
Like how do you even figure out what
the services are? Well, uh, they,
they came up with a list. A,
so the list kind of depends on the
ecosystem you're talking about because
different ecosystems provide
different services. For example, uh,
a salt marsh and we are in the water.
You're in the water.
What is it? A salt marsh?
Is that like the Florida
wetlands? But Salty,
I have suddenly don't know what
a salt marshes, salt marshes are.
Wetlands that are on
the coast. Got It. Yeah.
We're standing in about
a foot of water here.
We're quickly approaching high
tide Lisa and one of our producers,
Simon Adler to a nearby salt
marsh, partially the Hasan.
Your boots are much more water,
but really to talk to this guy.
My name is Adam Welchol and I'm the
director of science for the Nature
Conservancy here in Connecticut.
And Adam gave Simon a kind of inventory
of some of the services provided by
coastal salt marshes.
It's a stream of goods and
services with confided over time.
One of the things that does is it takes
water that's coming in from inland and
that laden with all sorts of
pollutants, all sorts of bad stuff.
The salt marsh will trap that water so
that the plutons settle and then very
often the marsh grass will suck up that
water into their roots and clean it up.
Yup. So you could ask very simply,
how much would you have to spend to
keep your water that clean second.
Well, there is one other study
I want to add them. Well,
she'll said that scientists in New
England have already figured that out. Uh,
for flood control, water supply
protection, pollution control,
it's roughly about $31 and
22 cents per Hector per year.
Then you've got to add the value of all
the plants that could meet the fished.
It ended up on our dinner
plate, $338 annually per acre.
And they're the birdwatchers that buy
lattes and support the local economy or
$190 per Hector. And then
there's habitat provisioning.
The list goes on and on and on and on.
You do get kind of obsessed with it and
you start like you started becoming an
accountant and writing down numbers
just furiously. Um, and uh, it
gets you to think about nature in a
different way than you had before.
There's this galling element
though, or this aspect.
Like when I first came
across the, at this point,
our producer Tim Howard jumped into
the interview and you'll also hear our
producers sworn wheeler in just a second.
I do feel like in an example like
the salt marsh, which cleans water,
that's all reliant on people
being there that need the water.
So if you didn't have people there, does
that Salt Marsh Sisa have any value.
But Tim, haven't you ever
had a conversation with
somebody who just doesn't get,
like if you make the aesthetic argument,
which is that nature should be,
should be preserved for its own sake.
There's a whole category of humanity.
It just doesn't respond to that argument
is this becomes a way to talk across
the aisle,
but it does still feel like it demotes
something of infinite value to something
of a piddly valley and really be infinite
value. I mean, like a mother's love.
You don't think your mother's love
is priceless. I mean, you know,
okay,
I totally accept that there is this
sort of priceless aspect of nature.
But if you are in the government
in a very poor country,
you have some tough choices to make. If
somebody comes to you and says, okay,
you've got these lovely mangroves
now. Uh, it turns out that that the,
the sort of setting where the mangroves
are is the perfect place for shrimp
aquaculture
because shrimp farms
need lots of seawater,
so it makes sense to put them by the seat.
We're going to put in these
farms, we're going to grow shrimp.
You are going to get New Orleans and
millions of dollars in tax revenue.
If you're thinking about the, the welfare
of all the people in your country,
many of whom are starving,
that might be a really powerful
argument into that kind of a discussion.
You can bring in the fact that these
mangroves are sitting there very quietly
doing all sorts of incredibly
valuable things. In fact,
they've done these kind of
calculations and in some cases,
the services that mangroves provide are
four times more valuable than what you
could get out with shrimp. So it's
stupid. It's just stupid in a bay.
A very basic sense too.
Wantonly replaced lots of
mangroves with shrimp aquaculture.
Is that a hypothetical situation? No,
that's a no, that's what we're asked.
This is Glenn Marie Lang.
She's an environmental economist for the
World Bank and she says very often she
finds herself in exactly
this kind of conversation,
particularly, you know, I
work for the World Bank,
so our primary clients are our
governments, Philippines, Vietnam,
and when you're talking to a minister
of finance and saying, you know what,
you I know jobs are jobs, but you
need those marshes, they have value.
They'll say, well, yeah, that's true,
but that means I'm going to have to
reduce the money that I put into the
education budget.
So you've got to really make a
strong argument about the benefits.
That's really where the rubber
hits the road. Well, I mean that's,
here's the counter argument.
It comes Doug McCauley and
ecologist of the University
of California, Santa Barbara.
The real danger is that we
actually succeed, that we,
we convince people that nature is
valuable because it makes money.
And then where we're really in trouble
in the many instances where it doesn't
make us money back, what do
you do in a situation? He says,
where say a bunch of rivers are running
dry and they're depreciating in value.
You know, by the same logic
that you train me to think with,
we should go out and liquidate
these natural assets.
That makes me feel really
uncomfortable. He says,
just kind of a weird way
to think about nature.
We had a proposal here in the state of
California to make gay marriage legal and
economists had a look at this legislation
and said this is expected to generate
$163 million annually for
the state of California. Um,
well it's good to know that.
I appreciate having that
information in front of me. However,
when I'm making a decision
on this legislation,
and I would say that when many
legislators, voters, average citizens,
so we considering the issues at hand,
they're not thinking about whether
they're going to make $160 million for the
state that are thinking about a different
set of values. On the other hand,
I want to say,
and this is based on my experience
working in developing countries,
that when you don't put a
value on these services,
basically they don't get counted.
They get implicitly assigned a value
of zero according to Glen Marie Lang,
and as we were debating this and going
back and forth and back and forth,
we bumped into a story about what
happens when all of these value of nature
ideas are let loose into a world of
fruits and trees and human uncertainty.
[inaudible]
the parable of the bees. We
heard this first from writer,
JB McKinnon who says the story begins
in Mao County in central China,
rural area, fairly remote,
lush green mountains filled
with apple orchards and a apple.
Orcharding was the main business and
according to JB in in the 1990s the wild
bees of Mao county slowly
started to disappear.
Am
there a few different
reasons given for that?
That could have been the destruction of
the habitat that the bees nested in the
heavy honey harvesting that wasn't
leaving enough food for the bees.
But the prevailing theory is actually
an economic one because in the 1990s as
China was shifting to
a market based economy,
apple producers were under
pressure to produce more apples.
So they started spraying pesticide
probably it was a constellation of all of
those things in a few others, a end
result is a stopped buzzing in Mal county,
which if you are an apple
farmer, that's a disaster.
As bees travel from flower to flower
in search of nectar, they are,
they're dusted with pollen,
which is the means by which flowers
engage in sexual intercourse.
So if you don't have the bees making
the birds and the bees on the blossoms,
then um, Ben, you don't get
fertile flowers to turn into,
to turn into fruit.
And obviously if you're a fruit
farmer and you have no fruit to sell,
you have no, so what do you do?
You're an apple farmer
and you don't have bees.
Then you need to find some other
way to pollinate the flowers.
And I guess they concluded, well we'll
have to do that ourselves by hand.
In Mandarin Chinese we say [inaudible]
show fan, so it would basically a,
that means a manual putting nation.
This is Harold t boat.
I'm a correspondent in China
for the French newspaper alone.
A couple years ago you heard about
the apple farmers in Mal County,
so he flies to Chengdu and he and a
friend hop in a car and we drive for like
five or six hours until we reach a this
village and mansion tiny little village
like around the a few houses. And then
we took our smaller roads in between the,
the fields and uh,
we actually saw that there were lots
of farmers in the, in the trees,
like on the apple trees traveling
on these often fin and spindly branches,
men and women that I've
seen in photos. In any case,
Harold and his friend took pictures
and if you look at those pictures,
you'll see the farmers
holding little brush,
little pollen brush that
they'd constructed using
things like chopsticks and
chicken feathers and cigarette filters.
And they'd have a little bottle filled
with pollen. And then what they do,
they dip the brush into the bottle and
they paint a flower blossom with the
pollen.
They dip the brush back into the pollen
and they paint the next flower blossom
again and then they dip the brush back
in again and they paint again and it dip
again. And they been
to make sure that that
all of the blossoms that they could
possibly fertilize would be fertilized so
that they would go onto produce fruit.
We're talking hundreds and
hundreds of flowers per tree.
It was very strange to see,
uh, uh, humans doing the,
the job of the bees. God,
what a pain in the ass
that sounds like. Yeah. The image of this,
of these Chinese orchardists standing up
in these spindly trees traveled around
the world through
environmental circles and it,
the message that it seemed
to send was that, you know,
this is what happens if you,
if you lose biodiversity,
you end up standing in the trees doing
the job that the bees used to do on the
wing for free,
for free. Those people just like human bs.
But then this guy interests the story.
This is Ian Son. Chen. Yeah. Human bees.
Four years ago he traveled to Mal county
to do a sort of economic analysis of
just how much the loss of the bees
was hurting the farmers of Mao county.
But what he discovered weirdly was that
the trees were producing more apples
than ever. Well,
production oil production,
this can be a confirmed zone.
More production for hand,
pawn nation, uh, apple chase
and uh, be punish apple tree.
You'll miss I'm white patient. Really
evil. We're doing it better
than the bees had been doing it.
Yes, a lot better.
Fruit production went up
30%. That's what the farmers told you,
which is kind of amazing. The all
new word I remember. Amazing because
I think Hemphill nation
campaign, h Massarelli a,
they can pollinate every flower and
bees don't. Pauline. Every flower
bees are a little bit, uh, you
know, they're a little bit, uh,
uneven when on their, they
don't like it. If it's cold,
they don't like it. If it's
damp, uh, they don't like it.
If it's windy in all those cases,
bees often decide to stay indoors
and just take the day off.
But you send people out there and tell
them to pollinate every damn blossom and
they're going to do it.
And there was the additional
benefit of the people that you paid.
They'd go to the bar,
they'd buy groceries,
they'd spend those earnings in their
local communities in a way that obviously
bees never did.
So here you had this whole story that was
supposed to be about how important the
bees are and this whole parable of
biodiversity turns up maybe the lessons,
just the opposite that actually we
don't need bees and maybe we never did.
If we only measure things economically,
then we might conclude that that uh,
some species are,
some ecological processes just aren't
necessary in certain places or that we
might even do better to,
to take care of those processes ourselves.
Right. So let me find my notes
about the wages. Exactly.
But there's one more chapter to the story.
Heraldo told us that when he visited
and then chin, I talked with one farmer,
his name is a Zanes ago. Is
there a certain age and uh,
he said in his opinion, uh,
do the hand nation, uh,
may disappear in a few years.
Apparently as China's economy
has continued to grow,
workers have started demanding better pay.
Xu wages are getting so high for the
workers that the farmers have to employ to
help them. Basically,
it's not efficient economically
to do the in nation anymore.
That's what a lot of farmers say this to
you. Now they're likely thinking, damn,
we need those bees back, right? Yeah.
Problem is there are no bees
are in those villages anymore.
One farmer told Harold beekeepers in
other parts of China aren't gonna bring
their bees to this area because they worry
about the pesticides that the farmers
have used. As for when
wild bees might come back,
whether for this we have a new idea. It's
very hard to make a prediction if you,
as the farmers, they're like, uh,
well, Bridget, oh, I don't know.
[inaudible]
here's where that story leaves me.
It leaves me thinking that economics
is just not a good way to go.
And putting an AARP a value,
even a even a precise and thoughtful
value on a bee or on a pound of pesticide.
You do it and you think you're
smart, but then the value changes,
the bees go from being worth a lot
to being worth nothing to being worth
everything all within a few years.
This, this is what markets do.
They swing back forth and we pretend
that we can predict but we never can.
So you can't put a value on cause you're
always going to be wrong or is it dumb?
When I, Winona I'm in love. I would
argue the other side for a second.
No where in the story did someone walk
into the middle of the proceedings and
say,
you know what, the bees do have
value. Here's the number. In fact,
you know Carl, when we were
talking to him, told us, you know,
there've been estimates that the value
of the pollination that comes from wild
bees is $190 billion. So
that's globally, right?
But still there was nobody in the
room giving that kind of number.
So the bees were inherently
valued at zero. But remember,
bees are valued at zero only until humans
get valued more than bees go down and
just go, I got to have a
lot of numbers in your head,
but here's what I like about this idea
is that when you put a number on a bee or
a bat or a marsh,
it's like an attempt to force a kind of
longterm thinking. You can't just say,
don't do that. I mean that's the thing
that like conservation to say don't,
don't, don't. But if you say don't
do that because here's the value,
here's the loss. Yeah, here's the loss.
Well then that actually gives
the whole precautionary,
don't think some teeth except for this,
that if you go businessy
on nature and you're wrong,
there are irreversibility [inaudible].
That's how environmental economists,
Glen Murray Lang boots.
This is one of the differences between
nature ecosystems and what we produce.
You smash your car, Hey, someone can
build a new one. If you lose the bees,
many instances you cannot bring them back.
So the question we got to is,
is there another way to think about
the value of nature in a way that's not
economic and therefore
shortsighted and all about us,
but also not simply about the
aesthetics and the beauty?
Cause that can be sort of limiting
too. Is there another way?
The Best I was able to do thinking
about this writer JB McKinnon again
was when it struck me that that in a way
all of this diversity that's out there,
all this biological diversity,
all these wonderful and amazing and
alien things that other species can do is
like an extension of our own brains.
There's so much imagination out there
that we simply could not come up with on
our own. That we can
think of it as as a, uh,
pool of imagination and creativity from
which we as humans are able to draw.
And that when we draw down on that,
on that pool of creativity
and imagination, we,
we deeply impoverish ourselves.
You know, in a sense we are,
we are doing harm to our
own ability to think and to,
and to, and to dream.
JB McKinnon's book is called the once
and future world. He's written many,
but this one is my fav
deep thanks to Carl Zimmer,
who's a reporting in the New York Times
on this topic is really what got us
launched into this whole thing and what
got us through this whole thing is Simon
Adler, who's production
assistants, was invaluable.
That was him freezing his ass off
in the marsh. I talked so long,
he nearly died. His toes fell off.
Anyway, thank you. So sir, thank you
Simon, and a thank you guys for listening.
I'm jet up and run. I remembered
[inaudible] we'll see you next time.